[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
welt ihr wisst ja ich liebe hefeteig und
tim schnecken nußdorf buchteln das sind
so meine lieblinge ich möchte heute
kennen sind von vollkorn überraschend
als veganer seit über zwei jahren und
heute gibt es deswegen vegane
zimtschnecken und ich habe mir gedacht
wir müssen ja im prinzip nur auf die
milchprodukte verzichten und auf die
eier
das heißt ich muss einfach was anderes
nehmen und nehmen statt der milch
einfach etwas mandelmilch ihr könnt
natürlich auch sojamilch nehme aber haar
familie oder was ihr eben gerne mögt und
ich werde natürlich auch bei der butter
einfach mir egal ob unternehmen bzw
kokosfett ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
für den hefeteig verwende ich etwas
warmes wasser einen würfel hefe 80 gramm
zucker 250 milliliter lauwarme
mandelmilch 500 gramm mehl einen halben
teelöffel salz etwas vanille extrakt und
50 gramm kokosfett hierzu erste hilfe
die kommt er in ein kleines gefäß da
kommt etwas zucker mit rein und ein
bisschen wasser jetzt kann ich die hefe
darin auflösen abdecken und dann an
einem warmen ort kurz stehen lassen so
mithelfen
ok und so kannte hilfe einfach schon ein
bisschen aufgehen ich mache den vortrag
und dann geht da hilft gleich etwas
schön auf dann geht es schneller schütze
anziehen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die hefe mischung hier ein
mal dieses volk gut aufgegangen
meinl extrakt das ist ja auch vegan
manchmal hierauf nutzung
damit muss man sparsam umgehen
kommt man vielleicht ganz kostbare salz
und zucker wartet das macht später rein
macht nur noch das meer ein
bist du stark und die angst die mandel
mensch gott jetzt kneten wir den teig
durch und nicht die finger rein strecken
geld ist ganz gefährlich
[Musik]
bisschen weiter weg und dann gebe ich
noch nach und mag dass kokosfett dazu
nicht mal darfst du mit der hand schönen
läufen festhalten und alleine aber an
die küchenmaschine davon nur wenn dir
mama dabei ist ja alleine geht das nicht
was kannst du wirklich wetter bessert
aktueller da wir beide auch soll es mir
doch mal ein mikrofon okay ab sofort
übernimmt die moderationen
[Musik]
potash noch so weich machen noch ein
bisschen mehr rein gern bei uns mal ein
bisschen zu viel wasser ja das war okay
das reicht ja ich glaube jetzt hat auch
festgestellt da ist weil ja das weiß man
als nächstes kommt
[Musik]
der teig das schmeckt sogar leicht nach
kokos bisschen mann koche ich gut
jetzt laufen wir ihnen hier noch kneten
machen schöne kugel raus und lassen sie
dann abgedeckt einen schöneren romans
löst sich dann steigt auch schön von der
schüssel
jetzt sieht man dass er gut wird der
samira gleichkommt mal so aussehen
[Musik]
stimmt nicht meint ausstecher aber den
teil kann man jetzt noch nicht
ausstechen
er muss sich jetzt ausruhen da hast du
deinen tag für dich
ich mache den jetzt einfach in der
schüssel und gibt da ein bisschen back
transport drauf das ist auch wieder
einfach so und bisher obendrauf
damit das herz aufgehen kann und nicht
austrocknet jetzt abgedeckt 1 stunde
raum macht schon respekt ran space so
kann ich bitte vermischen
ich denke jetzt ab und stellen den
backofen ich habe dann nämlich so eine
funktion also eine teig funktion und
dann brauchen nämlich nur eine halbe
stunde
ich gehe hier einfach auf dampf dann
gibt sie die gern stufe 40 grad sogar
unter auf 37 30 minuten und fertig und
das ist übrigens der wasserdampf damit
er nicht austrocknet
zeig mir wie du schnecke macht macht er
mal ganz ganz lange schnecke gemacht
eine schnecke machen maximal drei tagen
weiter fallen
[Musik]
da kannst du das alleine macht noch ein
bisschen länger dann kannst du mir
aufrollen
[Musik]
zigmal einmal lang machen eine konstante
schmecken
solange ich guck mal aber jetzt ist doch
schön lang und jetzt hast du sehr
aufräumt kann man da viel rolle und die
kann sich jetzt ausruhen und dann können
wir die schnecke packen und dann kannst
du dir später essen
[Musik]
damit lassen wir die schnecke ausruhen
und dann packen
teig ist es wunderschön aufgegangen und
so von der teig konsistent sein ist das
so wie immer manchmal merkt echte nicht
das ist ein veganer teig ich bin
gespannt wie er sich verhält wenn er
gebacken ist er riecht jedenfalls
richtig lecker nach kokos schön weich
jetzt einfach zu einem großen rechteck
ausrollen
[Musik]
je größer und dünner das rechteck jetzt
ausgerollt wird umso mehr schichten
haben natürlich auch später die schnecke
am sich das habe ich hier ein bisschen
vegane butter
theoretisch könnte ja auch nur 21
margarine nehmen irgendetwas muss man
halt nehmen gemeint regal lebt gibt es
halt keinen brutal satz ist einfach 20
margarine zum beispiel einfach schön
hier drauf streichen kokosfett wird hier
natürlich auch wieder geben und bis man
lasse ich hier noch was übrig
überstreichen danach jetzt habe ich hier
zucker und sind früher die beiden haben
sogar jetzt schön bestreuen
ich glaube ich sag's dir morath gar
nicht dass sie wegen sind das solltet
ihr einfach mal probieren und dann sind
wir mal gespannt auf sein urteil
der nächste optisch ähnelt und wenn ihr
jetzt noch schoko zentralen draus machen
wollt nehmt jetzt einfach zar peter
kuratorin dies nämlich auch vegan und
einfach ein kleines stückchen hacken und
hier noch dazu geben ich jetzt rolle ich
nicht so auf so hier von der kurzen
seite her
dann habe ich eine schöne geschichten
[Musik]
das sieht gut aus jetzt ganz wichtig
nicht auf der silicon matte schneiden
sondern ein schneidebrett unternehmen
sonst zerstört ist
jetzt einfach mit einem scharfen messer
etwa 3 cm breite stücke abschneiden und
dann in eine formel 1 geben
ich nehme jetzt hier eine weiblich das
habe ich vorher gefettet auch wieder mit
buck trend spray oder nehmt einfach die
vegane margarine wie abgemessen passt
perfekt ins blech irgendwie immer
komischerweise irgendwann weiß man
einfach abzuschätzen wie viel in so
einem blech passt ich werde mir jetzt
die zeit nehmen das ganze abdecken und
noch mal eine halbe stunde im backofen
aufgehen lassen und dann erst backen
beim weggang giftig ist ich weiß nicht
wie es sich verhält aber ich will es
einfach aufgehen lassen ich habe keine
eier mit drin und die eier seien ja
eigentlich immer dafür dass das schön
luftig und fluffig und fluffig wird
deswegen kurz aufgehen lassen und danach
erst backen
ich habe jetzt mal nach 15 minuten der
stufe einfach das ganze aus dem ofen
genommen denn die zentralen sind schon
ziemlich gut aufgegangen
jetzt kommt hier einfach noch die
flüssige butter drüber die vegane butter
und dann in den backofen zum backen
[Musik]
und erlaubten der nächsten ecke
ich hätte jetzt die zimmerdecken ok ich
muss zugeben freunde hat alles perfekt
in die frau reingepasst sie sind leider
zu groß geworden deswegen werde ich das
nächste mal diese große vor betrieben
ich mache es ja auch muss ich echt jetzt
sagen fürs foto nochmal das heißt morgen
gibt's nochmal veganer zum schmecken und
damit einfach fürs foto schön aussieht
aber der tag da ich einfach so luftig
geworden
also ich kann nichts dafür jetzt kommt
hier noch eine klausur drauf ich habe
hier einfach zitronensaft mit
puderzucker vermischt und bisschen
vanille extrakt so könnte die teams
stecken noch ein bisschen frischer
machen hier so drüber sprechen und für
schokoladen fanatikern und ich habe
jetzt hier ein bisschen kuvertüre noch
mal in einen spritzbeutel gegeben
inspektion in gefrierbeutel und einfach
in warmes wasser gelegt also in so ein
lied kann vor morath und jetzt fordern
eine spitze weg geschnitten und dann
könnt ihr nämlich hier im moment weiß
ein stückchen ausgerechnet das stück was
nicht geschmolzen nach vorne man könnte
jetzt nämlich auch ihn so darüber geben
und hier ist übrigens keine
dies gab mit der oma rausgegangen zu
spazieren so wolfram morath jetzt kommt
der vulkan hat gesagt er probiert heute
noch erzählt heute sind schnecken und
wieder ein video gesponsert von der
zahnärztekammer reutlingen und dem
diabetes verband das ist nicht so absurd
darf ich euch so in die hand geben ja ja
murat das erste waffeln backen
auch vorstellen locker müsste aber die
beste sind schneeketten sind die aus der
mutter egal jetzt im schnecken moratti
sind mega mega mit wissen der vulkan ist
veganer
ich bin gesund spaß so dass veganer ist
und ist immer schwer für vegane was zu
machen es ist schwer muss man sagen ist
nicht schwer denn glaube es aber nochmal
ein veganer hier bitteschön
guck mal der schnecke ist fertig dennis
hat gemacht schmeckt übrigens der anti
vegas liebsten weiß foto machen mit dir
und das schmecke was magst du am meisten
el salvador stelle schlägt sich macht
gleich ein foto von dir mit der schnecke
also falls ihr diese veganen hefe
schnecken mal nachmachen wollt dann
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei settings -
blog.de ich finde es echt gut ich habe
einfach mandelmilch benutzt man kann
natürlich auch die mandel mich selber
machen und der hefeteig ich echt super
locker kein stück trocken gar nichts
perfekt gut mal und ich mache dir ist
nochmal morgen in der großen form von
wenn sie auch wunderschön deutlich aufs
regal
er sagt ich soll der arme da guck dir
mal bin ich hier was kochen und backen
da musst du dem said muss ich mal was
von wolfgang backen dieses blech gehört
dir alles für dich einfach irgendwas zum
nächsten mal
es macht mir bekannt
[Musik]
jetzt die hebel schon aufgegangen man
kommt jetzt eine rührschüssel ohne
eiweiß er ohne eiweiß das ist eine
vegane ein veganer stadt selbst hat